first I want to touch on over watches
potential next character based on a
couple leaks and like lure from the
storyline and just things that someone
discovered just this morning for the
second time so sombra seems to be with
blizzcon come up on November fourth you
know like we're expecting a couple
announcements from blizzard not one
hundred percent positive what they are
but there are things leaning toward it
being sombra and maybe a game maybe
something else likely feeding into the a
blow three which we'll get into but um
there's new art found on the server for
blizzards official merchandise store
today and it shows like it confirms that
earlier leaked in game image of what
appears to be somber right here you
could see she you know she's standing on
top of a nom Nick robot she's but it
looks like a lot of people thought she
might be a hacker kind of tech-savvy
character we're not sure which class she
would plan to at this point as far as
speculation go so that's why I want to
talk to you about but the new image this
morning which is signed by John Paul
adoro he is listed as blizzards over
blizzard or overwatch illustrator
concept artists and character designer
so message like fours or whatever it
seems pretty official especially because
it confirms that earlier league has
showed the other sombra in game image
which showed her kind of looking over
her shoulder she has that SMG and like
right here you can see and she kind of
again she seems kind of cyber punkish i
guess like a lot of things in overwatch
but she seems she's got a hacker vibe
yeah maybe that's how i imagined hackers
to be I've never met one that I know of
Pete you wouldn't know no I know if
they're a good hacker but uh yeah I
don't know what like obviously with Anna
being introduced into the mixer on a few
months ago you know we knew Blizzard be
introducing new characters new maps to
kind of switch up things a little bit on
Oh was that you know like sniper support
hybrid class so I want to ask you what
you think like somber could be that
would benefit over watch as far as maybe
what class you'd fit into or what class
she appears to fit into maybe a hybrid
class yeah I mean it's it I mean just
right off the bat if I just want to
classify her just based off her weapon
like having an SMG just makes me think
okay so she's probably gonna be
relatively nimble or quick right like
kind of like I don't want to call her
like a tracer but it seems like she's
gonna have to be closer up because
generally in most games if you have like
an SMG
you want you like the shorts mid-range
kind of kind of character oh yeah agile
and it'll be interesting to see how the
hacking stuff ties into um how she plays
maybe it's her you know her ultimate
ability maybe she can like puppeteer
someone or take over someone mind
control them or something like that that
be interesting i don't know how balance
that would be but that seems kind of
cool if she could maybe like take over
someone and hack their mind or something
like that yeah again looking back at
hana she's being like her being the
hybrid class i had this crazy theory
about what somber could be because she's
standing on my comic the robots hand and
also you were talking about what like if
she did fill out a hybrid class what she
could be and then i was thinking how
would I got hybrid attack and tank work
which doesn't make sense until i looked
at battle born and there's a character
in battle born I'm called shane and RX
it's two people and it's one smaller
short girl inside of this like she can
be in this like rock golem i think it is
at certain points and then the rock
island plays more of the tank role while
she can escape and be more nimble
obviously this is just pure conjecture
but that was just an idea I had what if
she kind of is controlling this specific
amna cats a character in itself with her
but wouldn't that be too similar similar
almost a diva then because you're
piloting you know essentially a mech
organ um or whatever and like how do you
make another class that's not just like
diva and I don't know how you do that I
guess I mean it would be interesting if
she did kind of control like the robot
and maybe that's like all you're doing
or like you're one or the other anything
you're not both where's like the evo you
get the you know you get your mech and
then you can still fight in pilot mode
but I would be interesting to see I
guess because they need that the the
game like overwatch itself needs a pure
tank I feel like it needs another pure
tank cuz rinehart's really like the only
one that you can like say is like a
definitively a tank yeah just one more
like hybrid II when I play Reinhardt I'm
focused specifically on being a tank
whereas like road hog I'm actually
concentrating them like grappling people
and using my shotgun a lot more you so
you think a tank would be the most like
equalizing class to add at this point I
think there's a good amount of variety
in terms of like attackers and it's like
now with adding on a like the support
kind of class or sub trees like pretty
strong too I feel like adding another
pure tank would be the way to go but you
know I'm sure they have more characters
in the pipeline's because you know
sombras been talked about like for a
while now like people have been trying
to theorize like who she is what she is
how she plays like trying to find
several hints here and there so if she's
not the pier tank I'm sure there's
someone that's coming down the line
that's a tank because you know the added
of support if she is an attacker that
adding an attacker they're probably to
add a tank too yeah i mean the i think
the early things were would like the
comics whatever she was mentioned right
and then there was the Anana reveal
trailer the hand-drawn one if i recall
correctly showed a few characters it
disappeared when she was talking about
the old overwatch guards dying off and
then somber was one of you like the
shaved side of her head and then her
hair all in one side and she looked just
like this kind of in terms of her face
and sombra meaning like shadow and
Spanish because she I think in terms of
Lord somber the character has been
confirmed she's mexican and then
blizzard was saying that they were gonna
there were like rumors that was gonna
the announcement would be released
alongside like the Dia de los Muertos in
real real life in real time and
obviously blizzcon coming up in November
forth again would make sense if they
these things were leaking now I guess
more people were being more vigilant
finding them but i don't know i haven't
played over watching like three weeks
that's the longest i haven't really
played a match I think obviously when
they release Anna as is there in ten
that's when I got back in from all the
trial try her out as well as on what was
the German map that castle oh man I
forgot something I like it a lot um but
I don't know Pete have you played
overwatch much since release back and
whatever was no no no do you plan on
playing more maybe I had a spring you in
yeah no I mean I really want to I don't
think this additional character will
bring me in it's not about that just
about playing overwatch it's about time
I need that time yeah yeah but the game
looks so good yeah that's all I can say
yeah no I mean I'm always excited to see
what they do with new characters
obviously the characters are the
lifeblood of that game for me the
halloween stuff was good too so I mean
like if they can find a way to expand on
that brawl cuz like we we can kind of
guess that sombra is going to get
announced rate and then that either
there's going to be a new
app or maybe a new mode because I mean
like that mode was interesting in the
fact that it was you and some other
co-op players against like AI it was
also the same for characters you could
be right it wasn't in Korea was locked
out yeah in that sense rich light which
is weird for overwatch cuz like half of
overwatch is picking the character like
on a moment-to-moment basis it's
probably balance like you can't put a
bash sure no no no no I have fun without
just saying it was a Jurassic departure
yeah the overwatch formula as we
understood it um but yeah anyway that I
guess I don't know if there's any other
points to add again this is all
conjecture well no you're going down to
blizzcon Anaheim with Justin hey Walden
November fourth it starts the front it's
Friday and Saturday yeah so Friday the
keynote will be on it I think 10 a.m. if
i'm not mistaken it's either nine or ten
sorry that I don't have the time but you
that's basically the most important part
because it's like here's all our stuff
and then like if you're not there you
can't do anything else other than watch
it maybe maybe they PTR sombra I don't
know that that is a blizzard thing to do
but on that day one yeah on that day
yeah it's like guess what she's on peach
a Madonna when they released a trailer
right and you can play right now yeah
cool well that is our speculation
conjecture about sombra the potential
new character based on these leaks we've
seen if you've been playing overwatch
let us know what you think what you
think class you could fill out that make
you enjoy the game or leave your
thoughts in the comments below